good morning John I spent a bunch of
time with the dftba.com warehouse this
week because it's gettin into the busy
season not that they don't have it
handled I mostly just sign stuff it is a
really big place filled with a bunch of
really cool stuff we're with a ton of
amazing creators now Hannah Hart and
rhett and Link and glozell green and
minute earth and this star won't go out
and we sell shirts and hats and posters
and mugs and tea on this tabby that we
get to send people stuff that they like
and help creative people do what they
want to do for a living and today the
day after Thanksgiving actually
recording this on Thanksgiving and also
today after John you made a video about
how we are apparently incapable of
understanding how good the world is
comparatively you got to say sometimes
it is hard to keep in mind how nice your
life is my thought experiment here say
we cure cancer tomorrow Matt
celebrations right like people would not
be able to stop smiling for days and for
years we would continue feeling the
amazingness of that achievement to 20 or
30 years later we would still know that
it was great there would be less
suffering in the world less death but we
would normalize we just live in a world
without cancer how do I know this for
sure well it's happened before I mean we
used to not have antibiotics and
vaccines those things have saved
billions billions of lives and yet we go
on every day just sort of thinking yeah
you know the Fanta biotics and vaccines
they're nice but we aren't deeply and
emotionally touched by the Magnificent
magic that is this ability to not die
the way that humans always used to die
another example I was born into an
America where two people could be denied
the right to marry because of their
gender and so was everyone else watching
this video unless you are less than six
months old in which case guru Brut blue
you go we've already kind of stopped
being excited about that and maybe
that's good that were not designed to
say well I guess we've done pretty well
might as well stop progressing
objectively on average this is the best
time to be alive in human history I mean
I know I say that as someone who like
literally wearing like the most epic
thing I've ever bought on vlogbrothers
it's Thanksgiving I'm dressed up we
haven't seen so much to decrease the
suffering of people during my
grandmother's life there was a war in
which 60 million people died 60 million
my mother was born in
in America where black people had
different schools and different
bathrooms it's impossible to go through
life feeling all of these
accomplishments every second and maybe
we shouldn't maybe it's beautiful that
we move on from our successes and
immediately fret over the next giant
magnificent problem that we have to
overcome but if we never look back and
never think about what we've done then
it all looks hopeless it looks
impossible it is why it has to be a mix
of dissatisfaction with the way that it
is and what could be better and we have
to work for that and also recognizing
that we've done a great deal of
remarkable things as a species and as
individual like I get to live in a world
without smallpox and in a world with
twenty one pilots songs and pumpkin pie
one day a year of Thanksgiving is not
enough days of the year this is
something that I think really is
powerful and motivates me and makes me
happier and more effective just to be
thankful for the literal billions of
people who have worked hard to make life
better for their children and because
I'm one of those children and I hope
that I can honor the memory of those
people by both appreciating what they've
done and also building on it John I'll
see you on Tuesday in addition to
everything at dftba.com being 20% off
this week we also have bubble John and
also bubble Hank why do you look so
grumpy my hair is very very nice you can
make us kiss all that was actually good
don't do that
hello welcome the dear Hank and John or
as I prefer to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a collie podcast where me and
my brother John answer your questions
can you give me this advice and bring
you all the week's news from both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon and today we're doing
it live together